there's a good chance we're gonna have a
female president in 2016 have you heard
this Hillary Clinton woman apparently
she's gonna run for president that's
what everyone's saying and as we are
doing our big a spectacular show this
week I want to talk about why gays love
Hillary we were just talking about why
gays Florida don't love Barbara Walters
but gays love freaking Hillary Clinton
every gay loves her they just did a huge
fundraiser for her at the Abby here in
West Hollywood
tons of gays were there she's getting
all the money gays gays voted far more
for her in 2008 than they did for Barack
Obama what is it about Hillary and the
game well you know I think it's it's a
mutual appreciation because my first gay
pride parade was 2005 New York City in
the world of gay rights like that was a
lifetime ago like that was a very
different world than where we're at now
yeah and she was marching in that parade
yeah and I every senator from New York
yeah and I was like so impressed like
there she was with her rainbow flag and
so I think part of the reason why we
love her is because she supports us so
and not every day likes her by the way
can I personally in good conscience
can't vote for another Clinton or Bush I
just simply will not do it interesting
we left England for a reason and I don't
think that families I never had anyone
in my family that was president have you
guys not yeah yes oh I'm pretty sure
they don't need more of them you know
what I mean because then we're just
gonna have Melia 2026 I just think so I
just can't know I know an Obama really
sickening the worshipping of these
people do you think she's gonna suffer
in a weird way from every Democrat in
2016 is gonna be for gay rights right I
mean it's it's in the party platform so
in a weird way she's gonna lose a little
gay support because gays won't have to
vote at least democratic gays in the
primaries won't have to vote on gay
issues do you follow me I do she gets
seniority because she's gonna get she
gets more news simply because of her
history and you know and I wasn't at the
2005 Pride Parade it might have been 7
at the time I'm just kidding I wasn't 7
at the time but I remember her speech
for 30 minutes because she gave at the
UN yeah and that was also very
progressive I believe that was 2000 and
10:11 right and and and I was like
that's ballsy because she's speaking to
these countries that we've mentioned
earlier that are very conservative and
actually have laws that persecute gay
people and I so I think gays am i her
because because of the cojones the
people people to story too yeah she
would be she would be the first female
president and and I think like people
for better worse of people people that's
part of it like that's part of the kind
of the enamor and and that she's just so
incredible so this sort of goes to what
we were talking about with the view but
do you guys think that if there was a
gay male that had the exact same resume
I guess that would be tough because she
was first lady but if there was a gay
male who had the same exact in terms of
voting record and being Pro gay and all
that that the gays would embrace that
person I think the gays I know he's in
an umbrella well you know amongst us
boys we all know that there's plenty of
segregation discrimination within the
gay community as well someone's gonna
think he's to that someone think he's
gonna na someone's gonna want to ask is
he a top or a bottom and they're gonna
have an opinion about that i think i sad
to say i don't know if the gay community
would fully back a gay candidate i think
we have to look at the the gay
candidates or the gay congressman the
gay senators that currently already in
office and see what that kind of voting
record has been like but yeah
unfortunately we're just pickier I think
there's something about in and I don't
know how best to say this but that like
not all gay men enjoy seeing other gay
men succeed okay micro level bird there
that happens that like where they're
very quick to cut other gay men down
yeah so that's what I was talking about
with the view thing before so what do
you think that's about because I do I'd
absolutely think if there was a openly
gay candidate running for president that
had the same exact platform as Hillary
the gays would not be into him and I
don't know what the answer is I think
it's really interesting but on a micro
level you guys are gay youtubers I mean
don't you get plenty of hate from the
gay community oh yeah more hate from the
gay community then from the straight
community
it's just and I don't know so in your
own little world what do you what do you
make of that I think it's it's it's a
very complex question and I think I
don't know I don't know what the easy
answer is but I think what I have seen
is that gay men are very kind of quick
to cut each other down that it's like
and I think it's not something that just
happens in the gay world I think it
happens with women seeing other women
succeed I've heard this from my friends
and so I think it's like a phenomenon
that happens in marginalized communities
yeah it's not it's not a good look but
it's definitely yeah you agree I do I
think it's just a projection of our own
insecurities and the things that we had
to deal with and during our coming-out
process and it's and it's sometimes it's
difficult to be happy for other people
when it comes to their success and and I
was gonna say if you want to project the
public opinion on a potential gay
presidential candidate you can just look
at some of our gay celebrities now every
public gay celebrity entertainment
usually it can be a little bit of a
lightning rod for controversy even
Anderson Cooper who is pretty as vanilla
as they come people love them people
hate him and we're talking about just
the gays right